الاوكران باليد الاخرى. فما هي
النتيجة التي تريدها واشنطن من
ومتبادلا. الولايات المتحدة تدعم
اوكرانيا بيد وتمنع انتصار
المقاتلين في الميدان اذا لزم
الامر اعربت ايران عن رغبتها
الصين. حيث اكد وزير الخارجية
الايراني حسين امير عبدالله هيان
تطبيع مع مصر بعد ان واصلت تطبيق
الاتفاق مع السعودية الذي رعته
ان العلاقات الايرانية المصرية
تشهد تطورا وانفتاحا جديا
للطرفين. الامين العام لفصائل
المقاومة المعركة انتهت الا ان
وتحديد ممرات امنة للمدنيين
خالية من الوجود العسكري
قوات الدعم السريع ان المرحلة
الثانية للمفاوضات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
بدأت يوم الاحد في مدينة جدة
بوساطة امريكية سعودية. وبحسب
المصدرين ستتناول هذه الجولة من
المفاوضات تفاصيل هدنة جديدة بين
الطرفين من ناحية المدة الزمنية
الخرطوم بحر وام درمان قال
مصدران دبلوماسي سوداني واخر في
الاحداث والتطورات. بالتزامن مع
اشتباكات باسلحة ثقيلة في
والقضية. تمت عملية التصويت بما
يليق بديموقراطيتنا والحمد لله.
المناورات التي اطلق عليها عاصفة
الربيع نحو اربعة عشر الف جندي
فيه الاتراك عن الديموقراطية.
هناك **** مرشح تحالف الشعب
المعارضة التركية ان نسبة
المشاركة في الانتخابات الرئاسية
الحاكم رجب طيب اردوغان على
انتهاء عملية التصويت في
بلغت ثلاثة وتسعين فاصل ستة
بالمائة في رقم غير مسبوق يبحث
من احدى عشرة دولة في حلف
الناتو. فهل ترد روسيا عسكريا
والبرلمانية التركية التي جرت
يوم الاحد في عموم الجمهورية
التاريخ من اوسع ابوابه. اليوم
حطمت الرقم القياسي هنا اعلنت
الانتخابات البرلمانية والرئاسية
تايلاند اعزائي رفاق الدرب
الروسية قبل حوالي خمسة عشر
شهرا. اقتراع تاريخي. تركيا تدخل
نادر من قبل القيادة العسكرية
منذ بدء العملية العسكرية
نوع سو سبعة وعشرين وثماني عشر
طائرة مسيرة وتدمير عشرات
اوكرانيا في مواجهة مباشرة مع
روسيا. بل ان الغرب يمكن ان يورط
العقوبات ينتقل حلف الناتو الى
التحضير ضد اي توغل عسكري من
هذه المرة? نعم. الروس يتحضرون
للرد على اي خطوة غربية. وها هي
جندي اوكراني خلال يوم واحد.
بالاضافة الى اسقاط مقاتلة من
الاوكرانية اعلنت وزارة الدفاع
الروسية القضاء على نحو خمسمائة
الاليات العسكرية. وعلى غير
العادة اعلنت الوزارة الروسية
نفسه بنفسه. حيث قالت صحيفة
فاينانشيال تايمز ان دول مجموعة
ايضا سقوط قائدين عسكريين روسيين
على الجبهة في اوكرانيا في اعلان
ريدتا الصاروخية للدفاع ومدافع
من عيار مائة ملليمتر ورشاشات
خفيفة ومتوسطة ومنظومات لاطلاق
التوربيدات. فهل يدخل بوتين هذه
السفينة خط عملياته العسكرية في
اوكرانيا? وبالعودة الى الحرب
المشروع الحكومي عشرين ثلاثمائة
وثمانين. ويبلغ طول هذه السفينة
استونيا العضو في الناتو
لتدريبات مشتركة في قاعدة عسكري
مؤسسة احواض بناء السفن الشمالية
الروسية تعلن انها سلمت سلاحا
قريبة من الحدود الروسية. ووفق
مجلة فورين بوليسي يشارك في
موسكو عبرها الامدادات الى دول
مثل بولندا والمانيا. ومن
روسيا. حيث يجري حلف مناورات هي
الاضخم في منطقة اوروبا. وتستعد
ضد روسيا عبر استيراد الغاز
الروسي عبر خطوط سابقة ان خفضت
موسكو وتلقون بثقلكم لدعم كييف
بالاسلحة. فماذا لو ورطتكم
خطر المواجهة مع روسيا. فيا
لذكائكم يا هؤلاء تخافون مواجهة
السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي تعتزم
الحزمة الحادية عشرة من العقوبات
ان المسؤولين الالمان يرون ان
سيؤدي في الظروف الحالية الى رفع
وفق صحيفة جورنال فما الذي يخيف
الالمان اذا? تجيب الصحيفة ذاتها
مائة متر ومقدار ازاحتها للمياه
الفان ومائتان وعشرون طنا.
ويمكنها الابحار لمسافة اربعة
الاف ميل بحري في كل مهمة. فضلا
عن انها مسلحة بصواريخ اورانوس
الروسية المضادة للسفن ومنظومات
بحرية سفينة الصاروخية الجديدة.
والتي تم تطويرها في اطار
فيكتورت بموجب عقد بين وزارة
الدفاع الاوكرانية وشركة تصنيع
اسلحة كافية لدى اوكرانيا
لمهاجمة الاراضي الروسية ضمن
حيث لا تزال المانيا تعارض حتى
الان انضمام اوكرانيا الى الحلف
تقديم مساعدة فورية لاوكرانيا
باستثناء انضمامها الى الحلف.
المانية. لكن مالا عن اي عقد
يتحدثون هل ستدفع كييف الفاتورة
وعسكريا عند زيارته لبرلين. قال
زلينسكي لا توجد ني ولا قوات ولا
لاحقا? اما مسؤولو حلف الناتو
فيعملون على اعداد اقتراح حول
حيث كشفت تقارير المديرية
الرئيسية للاستخبارات في
الهجوم المضاد. وهنا يصل اول
الغيث الاوروبي بقطرة المانية.
اوكرانيا ان كييف ستتلقى اكثر من
مائة طائرة بدون طيار من طراز
نصرا اوكرانيا فلماذا تصرفون كل
هذه المبالغ على مساعدة
ايطاليا في طريقه لتحشيد
الاوروبيين لدعم كييف اقتصاديا
الفرنسية باريس وفقا لقناة بي اف
ام تي في. بعد ان كان قد زار
ليحشد دعما اوروبيا اضافيا. فهل
اهتزت ثقته بواشنطن زينونسكي وصل
العاصمة الالمانية برلين فجرا
ليغادرها عصرا الى العاصمة
الاوكران? هذا هو السؤال الذي
يتراود في اذهان الكثيرين.
الرئيس الاوكرانيسك تلقى الرسالة
الامريكية واتجه الى اوروبا
اوكرانيا. العالم يترقب الغرب
يدعم بكل سخاء. اما امريكا فتلعب
ملتزمين بالنصر المطلق
لاوكرانيا. اذا كنتم لا تريدون
على الحبلين باتجاه هجوم كييف
المضاد فيال هذا الهجوم الذي لا
احد يعلم متى يبدأ. لكن يبدو ان
هذا الهجوم لن يبدأ ابدا يا سادة
لقوات الناتو في اوروبا ان
الولايات المتحدة يمكن ان خطط
اذا صحت التصريحات حيث قال
الجنرال بن هوجز الرئيس السابق
الهجوم المضاد لاوكرانيا من خلال
الضغط المفرط على كييف. واضاف
هاوجز لموقع بيزنس ان هناك من هم
في ادارة الرئيس الامريكي غير
عناقها الحار مع الرياض. ايران
تمد يدها للقاهرة. واشنطن. تمنع
المعركة انتهت. ولكن المقاتلين
في الميدان اذا لزم الامر. وبعد
قياديين بارزين في اوكرانيا.
انتخابات تركيا تدخل التاريخ
اخرى من المفاوضات. فماذا عن
المعارك? المقاومة الفلسطينية.
وتقول كلمتها الاخيرة. والسعودية
تجمع الاطراف السودانية لجولة
سقوط اكثر من خمسمائة جندي خلال
يوم واحد فيما تعلن روسيا خسارة
لتدخل حربها؟ خسائر بالجملة
لقوات كييف في العدة والعتاد مع
بوتين يدخل وحش المحيط للبحرية
الروسية، فهل تسخن محركاتها
خططها بضغوطاتها المفرطة. بينما
زالنسكي يحشد الدعم الاوروبي
الناتو يفجرها. الولايات المتحدة
تعطل هجوم كييف المضاد وتمنع
الحرب الاوكرانية.